special guests thanks for joining us we
had Nick Riggle and the chief marketing
officer of ascension which is a major
partner of the Chess Club
good to be back I'm a little
disappointed Wesley NACA already drew I
was hoping for more fireworks on that um
where as one of those players your pick
to win the thing feel that yeah I love
knock I know we just won the Blitz yeah
but whenever they play it seems to be
too aggressive players a lot of
fireworks so a little disappointed
alright yeah well we got so much
full-blooded games this round so I think
the other players will make up for it
Nick tell us a little bit about your
work with the Chess Club and if
particularly in Ferguson sure so a
couple years ago now almost three and a
half years ago I partnered with the
Chess Club to create what we call your
mood chess which is an after-school
chess program for Ferguson and where
we're working with the Chess Club to
bring it to all the middle schools of
Ferguson as well as some other schools
in the area that were underserved and
now we've expanded to Chicago in
Nashville so we're branching out into
other cities and it's been a great
partnership it allows us to help get
kids playing the game much earlier in
life is you look at the B role there and
and the feedback has been excellent the
kids that are in the program really
enjoy it
they're performing better in school
their attendance is better than we're
excited about being there and so we
think it's a great concept and we're
hoping to continue to expand it that's
awesome I want to see every kid in the
United States get exposed to chess
what is the perfect age to get started
never too soon I mean at three four or
five years old as soon as you could
start talking and thinking and I think
it ingrains those habits in at a really
early age and so two last years we've
done fundraisers we have another big
event
on March 9th of 2019 where we hope to
raise you know another 150,000 or
$200,000 to invest back into the program
and make sure that every school in the
st. Louis area that wants chess will
have chess and that's really the goal is
to make sure that any school that really
thinks that their kids can benefit from
having chess has the opportunity and I
think it's really cool that's phenomenal
you know in Armenia all the kids learn
how to play chess as part of the program
the school curriculum and to see that
happen in st. Louis and then ultimately
have that be a model for all of us chats
how phenomenal would that be for our
children it'd be very phenomenon I think
it all goes back to Rex's vision I mean
ten years ago he started the st. Louis
chess club and I think has really
created state losses now the epicenter
of chest not only in the United States
with globally I think it's his vision
and his inspiration which is allowed and
encouraged me and others to do similar
programs and I can't thank Rex enough
for what he's done for st. Louis for us
chess and really for global chess I
totally agree now talking about global
chess beyond scholastics we totally
agree but just all that great clip about
the chess in the schools in Ferguson and
we've talked a lot about the benefits of
chess for kids but what about for adults
are there a lot of benefits that you've
seen as well because you've become more
serious about chess I have ever since
this partnership ever since the
partnership my son really inspired the
partnership but I've gotten a little bit
better I'm about 1600 rated on a good
day and you know the Chess Club started
at corporate chess League which is great
it gets adults like us playing and I
think there are a lot of benefits I mean
just as we age to play chess and get
better at it I think sharpens your
mental acuity
I think there's been all sorts of
studies about that and and I really like
the idea that this is something even
later in life I took it up later in life
and others have as well if you push
yourself and get better it sharpens your
intellect and I think it benefits you
and your work it benefits you in other
areas of your life so I'm a big devotee
of it my wife would say I played too
much Jess online but that's a different
story but I think you know it's never
too late to start playing chess and
playing competitive chess and and it's
something you can compete at unlike
football or baseball where you sort of
age out you never age out of chess I
totally agree I think that is really
important to focus on our adults as well
because those are the ones who teach the
children chess - so the corporate chess
leak what's that about
how is ascension doing so far well we're
own one but we're improving it's it's
really the vision of the chess club to
get big corporate entities Edward our
Jones ascension there's some others
coming on board
to field teams just the way we would
youwould a softball team a corporate
softball team or some other type of team
and so now we have chess teams and it's
a way to get to know your sort of
colleagues at different companies in the
st. Louis area be it's a chance for you
to bond with your own teammates I know
for us at ascension it was a great
experience practicing and then it's also
you know we're all still competitive
even as we get older we find different
ways to kind of venues for that
competitive streak to come out and I
think over the board is the best way to
do and so I love it I totally agree also
as a woman I feel like games like chess
poker making those like the corporate
networking games is so awesome because
it's really something that women and men
can absolutely on the same field and
it's really powerful it's not just about
kids and adults it's also about all
genders so very exciting final question
who is going to win this thing feel cop
you gotta get this one right what my
heart goes with Fabio obviously I want
it to be a great warm up to his match
against Magnus you know I think Magnus
is always the favorite in any torn mini
plays but I'm pulling for Fabi and I
hope both he and Magnus have a chance
I'm looking forward to their game next
week I think it'll pre preview I'm
curious to see if they really show each
other anything in anticipation of
playing again in London in a few months
oh yeah and we see them both there on
the screen that's right it's gonna be
this thing filled Saturday Oh Anna
Fabiano it does face a Magnus pressing
field Saturday
next week so don't miss it and his heart
is with Bobbie and his mind is with
Magnus who no said it better myself
thank you so much for joining me back